ексклюзивні кадри депутат Київради вже
встиг обладнати особисті апартаменти в
одному з кращих підвалів Солідар
Так це мій спальний мішок яка стара
кровать
значить
матрас і кусок подушки кожаної там десь
я знайшов на які я можу голову Ну я вам
хочу сказати це просто елітний житло
депутата погребіцького бачите в нього
вже є нерухомість своя власна солідарі
вже відвоював відвоював ну це круто
по мірках війни це елітне просто житло в
цьому підвалі по якому вже за останні 30
хвилин було чотири прямих влучання
Як до речі як до речі тобі спати під тим
як Наш будинок вже чотири чотири рази
влучив мінометр а-а Та ну якби вже давно
немає ніякого страху тому получанням по
мінометам по всьому Ну тут тут ніколи не
вгадаєш тут ну там на війні немає такої
штори Якщо ти будеш якогось там
алгоритму дій притримувати 100 там
Обов'язково все буде гаразд ми на такій
війні Що на стеву ракети прилітають про
що ми говоримо тут кожен посада в році
головний сержант проти головний тренер
проти з першого дня 46-й бригаді Да з
першого дня Ну взагалі я служив ще 95-й
бригаді був головним сержантом всю війну
ніхто не звертає увагу на які посадити
головна головна задача - це вибивати
ворога і робити Це як у мого ефективніше
от ми зараз в нас до цього була
курдюмівка це поля Там ми вибивали і по
суті успішні штурмові дії в нас були ми
видали противника але це поле це окопи
це постійні штурми це трошки простіше
Зараз ми в Промисловій зоні соледара і
це вже складніше було дуже багато
будівель противник намагається за ним
приховатися короткими перебіжками тут
дуже дуже
якби намагається сховатися перейти і
просунутися стріл і це вимагає від
бійців вимагає від головних сержантів
від тих хто організовує
спостережні пункти постійної уваги ну
кожну секунду кожну хвилину кожну
секунду треба все тримати під контролем
всі свої сектори вогневі позиції які ми
розставлялись командиром теж мають бути
постійно і готовності там зброя має бути
в постійному порядку завжди готова до
бою або Від цього залежить
ті ділянки які ми взяли під оборону від
цього залежить як успішно Ми зможемо в
подальшому просуватись вперед бо
ми заходимо з викличемо йдемо вперед ми
аеромобільні підрозділ ми і сам на
штурмує війська і навіть тут заходячи в
оборону Ну вже думаємо якби ми могли
просувати Вчора ми перехопили зранку
ініціативу У противника один з сержантів
це в нас бронік який з яким ви
спілкувалися ми запланували з ним
це перехоплення ініціатива воно було
успішності
противник не зміг розпочати шторм
оскільки цей штурм робили ми
Сьогодні ми відбивали атаки бо противник
вже трошки по-іншому алгоритму
задіювали знову ж таки все безуспішно
Оскільки тут стоять десантно-штурмові
війська і 46 бригада всі на своїх місцях
всі продовжують біль в нас
реально потужна бригада це я не знаю
напевно рідкість за всю історію війни
щоб бригада мобілізованих А в нас 90%
людей мобілізованих правда це в
більшості випадків це люди якісь так маю
на увазі які були википельному резерві
дешеве які мають досвід Да але от зараз
вже на цей час дуже багато людей які
вперше знову там вперше але люди бачать
наскільки професійних ефективно керують
відправляють командири боєм обстановкою
наскільки все це спокійно без паніки
відбувається як організована евакуація
зв'язок між підрозділами нашими І це дає
можливість людям бути впевненими що в
них все в порядку В тому Та все в
порядку з управлінням і вони можуть
чітко розуміють розраховувати Да і
рухатися виконувати команди з дуже
важливу історію
управління це надважливе історія
управління контролю координування
власними людьми це дуже важливо оце
впливає Я би сказав е-е якісний склад
офіцерський якісних вклад офіцери мають
е-е розуміти як керувати людьми мають
володіти обстановкою на лінії фронта
розуміти які в них сили і засоби ніяких
правильно використовувати для того щоб
виконувати задачі це дуже важливо тому
от Ми навіть у нас тут є придбані Люди
там прикордонна служба чи вона Ну щоб ви
розуміли нас бригаді воює навіть там
батальйон логістики і ротоохорони
це чудові хлопці вони нічого не
просплять вони дивляться
вони якби спостерігають якщо вони бачать
противника вони по ньому працюють
і ми в цих хлопців впевнені хлопці
впевнені в нас ми працюємо якщо мені
треба Я розумію що вийти прикрити спину
Так як вчора було Ми з Медиком в нас
вони десь там повинна вийти прикрити
спину на посту ми виходимо прикриваємо
спину хлопцям на посту якби якщо треба
відпрацювати з АГС бо там трошки Важка
ситуація я там виходжу з хлопцями ми
працюємо собі якщо треба відпрацювати
ваші все другими мінами з РПГ і
підтримати хлопцями працювали дуже
важливо кожен боєць має вміти працювати
з РПГ скулими та з усіх видів зброї ти
маєш бути На цій війні у універсальним
солдатом тоді ми будемо досягати успіхів
головний сержант проти погребицький він
же в універсальний сержант універсальний
депутат Київради
працює в Києві але опікується на даний
момент захистом соледару Дякую друже за
службу і за цю розповість дякую